greetings
greetings hello so my name is alex
markey and i am an instructor in the
laboratory of closed lay at the lahoo
institute
and um and thank you very much for this
opportunity i'm delighted to share with
you our recent work a recent results uh
about the discovery of elongated
neutrophil derived structures
so but i will tell you a little bit more
than just these structures because uh
the way to discovery of these structures
led us through uh
neutrophil rolling and tatters of
neutrophils and i would like to give you
a little introduction of those
things as well
so
neutrophils are the most abundant cells
in in the human blood most immune immune
cells in the human blood
and the
the primary role is is
protecting us from infections and
bacterial fungal infections
and they also have a role in tissue
remodeling so neutrophils are made in
the bone marrow and from there they are
released into the blood circulation
and with the blood they travel to
all sites and the human body
um and if they encounter an inflamed
vessel wall then they um begin to
extravasate into that tissue
and this extravasation cascade is is a
multi-step uh cascade
that
entails the rolling of the neutrophils
on the vessel wall
and this is what the movie shows you as
well here introvital recording
and then rest and crawling on the vessel
and turns migration into the
extravascular space how this what is the
last picture here last section of this
cartoon
so um
in the lay lab my my
work focuses on on the rolling part of
this cascade
and one of the
very exciting questions for us is that
how can the neutrophils maintain rolling
under these tremendous forces exerted by
the blood stream
so rolling neutrophils velocity is about
a thousand times less compared to the
blood flow velocity so they really need
to cling on to the vessel wall to
survive that
and uh well one of the
mechanisms that enables neutrophils in
it is called the tata formation
so that is our long same
membrane structures pulled out
from the adhered microvilli of rolling
neutrophils
on this movie here you see um
mouse neutrophil bone marrow derived
neutrophil that we labeled for plus
membrane this is the green channel
and um this this this is a side view
flow chamber microfluidic device that we
designed specifically for the purpose of
visualizing the tattered formation from
a lateral perspective of the rolling
cell
so
what you can see here is as the cell
rolls by these long thin structures form
behind it
and
here on the still images you can observe
these uh
structures with a higher signal to noise
ratio
you can see that nutrition can form
multiple of these that the tatters at
the same time
and with multiple lengths as well
now there are actually quite a few um
in vitro
studies out there which which
looked at the structures in different
techniques
um and and in vitro it is um well
established that that there are actually
load bearing structures
so
however uh just until we
did some introverted work it was not
known whether this is true in vivo as
well or not
and in the next slide
i would like to show you
a little bit about this in vivo work
that we have done into the direction
so to to interrogate whether tatars form
consistently in vivo as well and whether
they are load bearing in vivo or not we
turned to the cremaster interview
microscopy model
so in this model we prepared out the
cremaster muscle of anesthetized mice
and these muscles are very thin and
highly transparent so they offer a great
uh
opportunity for high
detail imaging
and we injected these mice with antibody
against the neutrophil surface that
antibody was
against the ly6g surface antigen
and this is what the magenta color shows
you here
and so we have seen multiple examples of
data formation of rolling neutrophils
like here you see three columns each
column shows you
like consecutive frames of
of the same cell rolling
from left to the right
and you see this uh thin structure
behind the cell
uh around the third frame or maybe even
the second frame and the third column
these these are the tethers that we have
observed and to to
investigate or to test whether um these
that have a load bearing what we did is
we measured the
rolling neutrophil displacement
right before and right after
the disappearance of the tether
so
um right
right after the disappearance the
neutrophil
rolled a little bit longer uh during
that frame time indicating that when the
tet air fails the neutrophil makes a
jump makes a short acceleration
and
as you see here on this on this plotting
in most cases the
displacement right after that air
failure was longer compared to right
before the death failure so most
neutrophils make a jump after that data
failure
this suggests that that there's our load
bearing structures in the evil
as well
so
next to
during these experiments we have
observed
many elongated structures on the vesicle
and these elongated structures with
lysisg positive which shows that they
are derived from the from neutrophils
their magenta uh positive lysisg
positive
and um what we observed is that
some of these
elongated structures are
stuck to the west of all others were
sliding along the vessel wall and yet
others were circulating with the
bloodstream
so when we took blood from these mice we
were able to detect in the blood plasma
these elongated structures as well
we we name these structures as elongated
neutral derived structures or shortly
ends
so this name
entails that these structures are
elongated and neutrophil derived
uh well
we of course we're wondering how do
these structures form and
from our perspective the most plausible
explanation was that these form maybe if
this form when neutrophils
lose their tatters
so
and indeed we could find some examples
for that
uh in this movie in this montage you see
a neutrophil is rolling from the left to
the right
and as they roll some of them leave
behind tethers or elongated structures
on the western wall
and
those those ends
are indicated with the yellow rectangle
and
as they
um as of these neutrophils formed ends
uh actually they they showed unstable
rolling velocity unstable rolling as
well
this is what you can show what you can
see here now on this graph
uh so the full circles indicate the
rolling velocity of ends forming
neutrophils and their speed was
always higher than
uh of the velocity of the non-ends
forming
the cells
so
from this uh these observations um we
concluded two things one is that
um
the tatters are indeed load bearing and
data failure will
result in um unstable rolling just as
expected
the second thing is that
uh since in our movies we have seen only
about um seven six or seven percent
neutrophils showing data failure we
thought that this might be connected to
um some subset of of the neutrophils
um
so we didn't follow up this question yet
but this will be very interesting to to
find out
whether this is true or not and which
subsets are prone to teta failure
so so far i have shown to you um results
uh measured on on maus neutrophils
and to link this to human
setting
we have turned to
flow chamber experiments
on uh human neutrophils isolated from a
healthy human donor's blood
we label the nutrient surface with a
cd16 antibody
and
these antibodies uh um they label very
homogeneously and brightly denote the
surface
and we expose them to
stepwise increasing shear stress and as
you can see as the shear stress uh
becomes higher and higher or the flow
increases neutrophils start to form more
and more tethers and they start to
fall off from the vessel wall from the
flow chamber wall and leave behind these
elongated structures
to analyze this uh uh to quantitatively
analyze these records we have developed
an
image segmentation
method with imarus that allowed us to
specifically
gate on
the cell body or the tethers and or
the ends
in these records
and
what our analysis showed of these movies
is that as expected with uh
increasing uh perfusion rate uh the
cells showed um increasing rolling speed
and on on e selecting substrate the
rolling was more stable than on the p
selecting
and um
with the increasing shear stress more
and more cells fall off from the vessel
wall
and uh
additionally so that the most relevant
to this
topic here is actually that with
increasing shear stress um the
neutrophils formed more and more and as
well
um so we quantify this by measuring the
total area of the yellow signal on these
records
so from this we can conclude that
human neutrophils
can do the same thing even though we
have in vitro evidence for that only
and that
ends formation is related to the shear
stress level
so
i mentioned to you earlier that the
elongated structures were also um
detectable in the blood plasma
and you know this this raises the
question so how do these structures get
into the blood
since they form on the vessel while
somehow probably they they detach from
the vessel wall or or what exactly
happens there
so what we have observed as well that
uh the
ends
are forming in at the end they they
uh the sliding ends
often detached and went into the
circulation
so on the upper movie here you can see
a venue a small vein of a mouse
and the
yellow rectangle shows you how
an end
slides on the west side of wall and
suddenly disappears suggesting that it
detached from the vessel ball that was
at that point
so it looks like an ends form they can
slide along the vessel and then they can
suddenly detach from the vessel and go
into the circulation
um so to to to model this in a flow
chamber uh what we did is we we prepared
the flow chamber which was half coated
with the um
selecting and
have so half of it was coated with
selecting the other half was not coated
with selecting
and in these half coated chambers
we could um recapitulate this
observation that
sliding ends they detach when
they reach a
certain point where there are not enough
adhesion molecules on the on the wall
so uh
in
in the microcirculation it is known that
selectings are mainly expressed in the
venules small veins
and their expression density decreases
as we
proceed further toward the larger veins
so
an explanation for
ends
getting into the circulation could be is
that as they slide these ends they reach
a level there um there are not that many
selections anymore and they just fly
away with the flow they cannot hold on
anymore there
so to summarize these uh um
these things that i showed to you so far
uh here are three pictograms the first
one shows you that um drawing
neutrophils they form that is and the
second one shows you that the status
break off from the rolling natural
fields and the third one shows you that
the the remaining uh ends they either
stick or slide on the vessel or
circulate with the blood flow
so um
next we we thought that these ends these
are
new category of of the particles by the
neutrophils
and to put them into context we turn at
the literature we looked around what
are mechanisms of neutrophils
and there are actually already at least
four
such secretary mechanisms or or major
secretary mechanisms described out there
um
so as the neutrophils get closer and
closer to the inflamed tissue they get
more and more activated and they release
more and more things into their
environment
and they do that by extracellular
vesicle release
which these are the exosomes and
exosomes and apoptotic bodies
then they do that by
dna release this could be mitochondrial
or nuclear dna
release
or net formation which is standing for
neutrophil excess cellular trap
formation and neutrophils also release a
lot of substance through degranulation
and migrating neutrophils can also leave
behind trails
as they go through the tissue or go
along the vessel wall
and so we think that the
end
is is in addition to this to this group
to the secretary mechanism group
and ends release is actually connected
to rolling of the neutral fields
so
next we aim to characterize us a little
better these ends
and uh so we performed the correlative
factor microscopy experiment which
confirmed that the there
this is an own data structure
and we also did storm imaging which
confirmed that the diameter of these
structures is about 115 nanometer
next we
did some
microscopy experiments to find out
whether ends contain any organelles and
we found only cytoplasm inside no er no
mitochondria no nucleus or dna
then we set up an essay for protonomics
analysis
so for this we um we optimized a flow
chamber experiment for
producing
um
as much as possible
ends without neutrophil contamination
and for this we applied a couple of
tricks
so we have rolled the neutrophils in
these chambers in the absence of calcium
magnesium
to avoid the rest of these cells
on the other hand we
we increased the
p selecting coating in these chambers to
uh
to allow the cells maintain
um
effective rolling under these low
casting low low magnesium conditions
um
then
after producing these ends uh production
of ends we wash through the chamber at
high flow to get rid of every possible
cell which could clean one somewhere
and after that we harvested the
ends with the
sds buffer
and then we run lcm sms protonomics on
these samples
so the results showed us that
ends are
enriched for
a couple of proteins like 57 or so
proteins compared to the whole
neutrophils
and
but here i would like to focus your
attention on the s100 a18 a9
proteins
which are
uh
known inflammatory mediators these are a
damage-associated proteins
in in humans and also in mice
so
uh next
we what we asked we wanted to see
whether the uh um ends could be a source
of
protein s188 and a9 in the circulation
or you know in an in vitro experiment
like this one here so we produce ends in
a flow chamber
and
the first we image these structures over
four hours
to see how the shape changes whether
they degrade or not and we found that
they indeed they degrade they round up
and they become uh shorter as well this
is what the graph shows to you here
so the the red curve indicates diversity
of the ends and you see that that it
increases over time and you see the edge
size with the black curve it decreases
over time
so
from this we concluded that ends they do
round up with time
or degrade and we measured in the
supernatant of these chambers with an
elisa
uh kit the s1889 complex
amount and we found that with time the
quantity increases
uh so with time these structures uh
release more and more and uh more and
more uh um s108 and a9
so to add this information to our
summary slide here we added the new
pictogram that indicates
with time and they degrade and they
release s 108 a9 and possibly other
mediators as well
into the circulation
uh this this
symbolizes with these yellow dots
so
to
find out you know the relevance of this
to human health and disease or to put
this into a human context
we
turn to uh
septic samples and we have the question
whether we can detect ends in blood of
septic patients or
so we wanted to test uh whether this is
true or not in a human disease context
as well
and
for this
we
decided to analyze the blood of septic
patients
so for for this type of for for a
quantitative screening method we we
developed an image stream or imaging
cytometry based scanning approach
and
in collaboration with you of atman
at sanford burnham and so why this
instrument was ideal for us is because
this instrument gives information about
the shape of the microparticle as well
so how this instrument works well
imagine this is a flow cytometer but
instead of one data point for
each event you have one picture for each
event
and um you can run
all sort of image analysis on that
picture and from that you can
derive the shape of the of the object
so
um i'd like to show you here some
technical details about this scanning
so first the labeling approach
well we
generally we used a double labeling
approach and the goal of that was to
label the ends with
two different color antibodies so that
we will we would be able to
um distinguish between antibody clamps
and between real objects
so
we took only those um events real
neutrophil derived which were positive
for both color antibodies like lysix g5c
and license g647
or in case of humans
cd66b fit c and cd16 647.
so
the goal of this was uh essentially to
to analyze the shape of these particles
and for that the gating strategy is
shown here under the third point
so
with this method uh
we were able to detect
significantly increased demand of ends
in blood of
mice injected with lps
so before injection
the mice had almost no end in their
blood and two hours after lps injection
they had um significantly increased the
amount about
600 700 and per microliter of blood
plasma
so
for the human uh
scenario we collected blood plasma from
septic patients that were diagnosed uh
based on two or more surf criteria
and uh suspected infection
this was very heterogeneous
population
as you see
they had all kind of primary and
secondary diseases well this is a
general problem for sepsis research for
the field this is a very heterogeneous
disease group or patient group and it
requires a lot of effort to stratify
properly
the
results for the septic
samples looks the following
so here you can see a raw data that was
generated by the image stream instrument
and the upper block here you can observe
the spherical objects
so all of these objects are double
positive for cd66b and cd16 which gives
us assurance that they indeed come from
neutrophils and they are not um antibody
clones
so
in the um amongst the spherical objects
we could observe examples for double
positives for anaxine and tetraspanins
and also a double negative for both or
one negative oneplus d for each one of
these
uh on the other hand we also detect as
multiple examples for
elongated
objects or ends and this is what you can
see in the lower block here and these
ends were all negative for tetraspanning
and on xin5
so
we were interested in
in the shape of these objects that's
what we used to call an object ends or
or a spherical object
and to do that we measure the aspect
ratio of these events
the aspect ratio is the
ratio between the height and the width
of
of the structure
and so if something is a perfect sphere
then it will have aspect ratio one
and if it would be a perfect line then
it would be zero or very very close to
zero
so as you see the shape of these objects
changed along a continuum and so we had
to pick somewhere i cut off
and that cut off
we chose at 0.6 aspect ratio so
all the objects that were that had
aspect ratio less than 0.6 were
elongated uh for us and we call them
ends and those which were which had
aspect ratio larger than 0.6 were
spherical and we um
call them um so we think that they might
also entail the fragmented or
degraded ends as well
so on this graph you can see
septic and healthy
data
the septic one is indicated with gray
symbols and the septic excuse me septic
is the gray symbols and healthy with the
with the black symbols
and
we compare
the
total end count in healthy and septic
conditions you can see that there is a
highly significant difference between
the two
additionally
we measure the
s108 a9 content of blood plasma
in healthy and septic patients and what
we saw is that in uh um in the
in the septic patients there was a
correlation between the
uh s400 a8 a9 content and the number of
fragmented ends
so
the fragment and they are spherical
shaped right
and
they they have aspect ratio larger than
0.6
and our in vitro experiments indicated
that um
in the supernatant of fragment that ends
uh more and more s108 a9 appears with
time
so
uh which looks back to our in vitro
imaging and and suggests that
um end degradation happens in uh in uh
in humans as well in the blood blood and
it will result in increased as far as
the
a9 content of blood plasma
so
this is uh what we published in our
recent publication
with the mouse and human evidences
together and from here on i would like
to show you some data that is not
published yet
so
when looking at this cascade you know
multiple questions could arise and i
just picked two questions here
um that i would like to further discuss
with you first one what could be the
molecular mechanism of data failure in a
second what happens to the ends in the
circulation
how do they get cleared
so to address the first question
um we i would like to show you a little
bit uh on the
um
the connection between the plasma
membrane and the affecting cortex of
eukaryotic cells
so um
it was established already about 20
years ago that um phosphonocitides can
anchor together
or have an important role in anchoring
together plus membrane with affecting
cortex
and
there are these anchoring proteins
which uh can bind uh phosphoenols these
are these um yellow structures in the in
the plasma membrane and
and the affecting
um
so and it was also discovered that um
upon stimulation of uh phospholipase for
example through inflammatory mediators
um this
uh
this bridge can be broken up by cleavage
of the
phosphoenositis
and
so when when this
axis breaks up the plasma membrane
plasma membrane becomes easily
extractable
and the cell
will lose membrane
from itself
so
to test whether this
mechanism could have a role in tata
failure
we set up some uh inhibitor experiments
so
we expose the cells to phenylalanine
oxide and worth money to block its pi4
kinase activity and and decrease the
phosphorylase type
phosphate content in the plasma membrane
and they also expose the cells to
lateral chronie and also ionomycin
and on the next slide i would like to
show you the results of this
so
here you can see um
mouse neutrophils rolling um in in the
flow chamber uh
and these neutrophils were either
untreated or were treated with uh latin
a phenylalanine oxide or worth money
inhibitors
and as you can see
uh the control cells under these
conditions did not form ends
they didn't leave behind ends
um on the other hand the electron
cooling power and horseman they did
they did a lot of ends formation
so
this um
to further
test this
the relevance of this mechanism into
that failure
we set up an experiment
uh where we could expose the neutrophils
to uh inomycin rolling into this
ionomycin so this is a tricky experiment
because inomycin
which is an ionophore and it induces
the stream streaming of calcium into the
intracellular space
it activates the integrands of the
neutrophils and makes them rest suddenly
so to come around this problem
we have uh turned to age of 60 cells
undifferentiated age of 60 cells which
don't have complete integrin machinery
and therefore they cannot be arrested by
inomycin
uh furthermore we transfected these
cells with the
pip2
biosensor phpsc
rst
and
we roll these cells on a
selecting substrate
and
we superfuse them with dynamicin
and what we observed is that
when the ionomycin reached the cells
these asia six cells started to form
many many long tatters
the pip2 biosensor detached from the
plasma membrane and spread all over the
cytoplasm
and eventually these
tethers they broke off from the cell and
they became ends
um
this further provides evidence that the
uh phosphoenocetides
affecting uh
bridge or or axis holds together the
cell and it has an important role in
tata failure so based on that we have
further candidates in mind to to
dissect further what could be the
molecular mechanism behind that here you
can see a brief list of these candidates
bar proteins erm proteins or myosins
so next uh
topic that i would like to touch on
briefly is that what happens to the ends
in the circulation
well to
addressed this question first we did
an experiment where we injected the mice
with
lps to induce endotoxemia and then we
blood these mice
multiple times following the injection
and we measured in each sample the ends
count and what we found is that what we
found is that the um
ends count they drop
after four hours and eight hours in the
blood suggesting that somehow ends
disappear or they degrade or they are
removed from the circulation by some
sort of mechanism
well to
further investigate this
we have
you know
we have set up some uh mesentery imaging
experiments
so for this we have designed uh a new um
in mouse preparation stage
and with the app of that stage we
imaged the mesentery circulation
following lps injection
so
without
lps injection uh we saw many neutrophils
rolling on the vessel wall here this
what you see here on the left uh movie
and however one and a half hours after
lps injection these uh
the video couldn't see any ends on the
western wall and we saw
just a few neutrophils rolling and we
saw mostly cytoplasm actually along the
russell wall
so but you know the bottom line is that
the ends were not visible in this
vascular bed even though we injected the
lps right there
so
where did the ends go from here where
did they disappear within one and a half
hours
um
so
next we injected the uh we set up
another experiment where we um
where our goal was to image the uh
cremaster muscle
um
through one and a half hours following
lps injection
and this experiment showed us that um
after lps injection even though
neutrophil rolling is not
apparent in these in this vascular bed
the ends they just start to appear
on the vessel wall without apparent
neutrophil rolling
here you can see
some examples of this
so
about one hour after lps injection
the movie shows there are some elongated
structures along the microwave
micro vessels of of the cremaster muscle
and here you can see some snapshots
of these uh elegant structures so from
this this suggests that um
following lps injection into
intraperitoneal space uh the uh ends
they they
probably forming that vascular bed and
then they travel around with the
circulation and they stick to the
cremaster microvasculature
so
uh ends might populate other organs than
the uh the origin organ of origin
like this they might contribute to
remote organ injury however these are
preliminary results and of course it
requires um further investigation
so
um so this suggests that ants could
travel and stick to all sorts of vessel
beds in the inflamed body
and here i would like to show you one
more data um regarding what can happen
to the ends so we found that monocytes
and macrophages can phagocytose them in
a flow chamber
on this movie here you see how a human
monocyte picks up human ends in a four
chamber
as you see over three hours it is it is
cleared up very well
and on the next movie you can see how a
mouse macrophage cleans up
mouse ends
again in a flow chamber experiment
so
this suggests that uh these ends they
could be cleared from the circulation by
uh
monocytes and macrophages so to complete
these pictograms uh this this summary
slide we added here two two drawings one
suggests that
one shows that um ends they can populate
remote organs they can stick to the
vessel
after prolonged circulation probably
and the last one here shows that ants
can be phagocytosed by
monocytes and macrophages
so with this i would like to thank your
attention and these are the great people
with whom we did this work
and thank you very much